[Music]
i love jeopardy i think many of us do
love jeopardy i'm starting to think alex
trebek
has been hosting that show too long
i really believe that yeah oh i know
gasps
what's conan saying i've been watching
i'm afraid he's getting up there and
he's starting to lose it take a look
onomatopoeia for six please
puff daddy puffy pee diddy shitty
whatever he was born with a lumpy body
covered with
what is warts butter peanut butter uh
let's go college for four
ben franklin used a genetically altered
gluten-free virgin to prove that sexism
weighs as much as a duck
barred or leonard
he killed the fatted calf back to you
nilon uh let's go to their history for
2000 please yay
a body covering garment having a veiled
opening for the uterus is worn by muslim
dykes to play batman on the big screen
hope you kids enjoy that
eli river
who is christian bale
back to you leonard celebrities 400. in
an interview with oprah nicholas cage
claimed to have the heart and stomach of
a mythical warrior
extracting eagle tears to cure writer's
cramp in monkeys and parrots
that would be eagle-eyed
uh celebrities 600
oh my miley cyrus blew 240 000
marsupials by using a vacuum pump in a
trailer park perhaps contributing to her
violent hatred of muskrats and mankind
barrett what is scientology yes that's
it
someone got one right
finally